[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes le lundi 30 décembre
bienvenue sur tv 60,18 faisons ensemble
le tour de l'actualité locale et pour
débuter direction les bords de seine le
fleuve connaît une crue habituelle selon
l'organisme en charge de sa surveillance
mais le niveau jaune a malgré tout était
enclenché à poissy l'accès à certaines
promenade a même été interdit en
reportage manon varaldo pas de pause sur
c'est bon pour les riverains et pour
cause la scène monde certaines promenade
au bord du fleuve sont interdites en
raison de la montée des eaux la ville de
poissy à fermer le chemin de halage qui
longe l'ancien pont de la ville des
barrières sont rajoutés pour empêcher
les riverains les plus fougueux de
braver l'interdît pour cette habitante
de poissy depuis deux ans c'est la
première fois qu'elle voit la scène
aussi haute
je suis en bordure des zones inondables
donc je croise les doigts pour que ça
soit vrai et quand je me balade donc
souvent avec mon chien ici j'ai vu que
ça a beaucoup bougé et je me suis dit
énormément de maisons en zones
inondables
donc c'est vrai que ça peut être un peu
inquiétant un autre habitant de poissy
observe l'augmentation du niveau de la
scène avec son petit-fils alors je
constate que devant les surgeons ça déjà
lyon dès le passage est fermé bon ça
monte pour l'instant doucement la scène
et certains de ses affluents ont
toutefois été placés en vigilance jaune
l'esturgeon le restaurant le plus proche
du fleuve a connu d'autres événements
marquants le directeur de
l'établissement est ici depuis 1986 on
se prépare parce que à partir du moment
où la ville commence à barricader les
bords de seine comme ça c'est que
ils ont des informations comme quoi ça
risque de monter donc on fait quand même
attention en 2016 c'est au mois de juin
donc complètement inhabituel où on a eu
une grosse grosse inondation suite au
des intempéries très nombreux à ce
moment là en 2010 8 janvier on a eu beau
être très très grosse inondation ou là
on a été impacté on a réussi à tenir
ouvert et là est bien le but avec la
crue de la seine les piétons ont été
remplacés par les canards et les signes
eux se réjouissent et pataugent
tranquillement dans le reste de
l'actualité locale voici lé image un
mois après son installation du radar
dernière génération installé le long de
la rn 184 à saint-germain-en-laye
l'équipement qui scrutaient la
circulation en provenance de conflans
sainte honorine a été sciée durant le
week end
l'auteur ou les auteurs n'ont pas encore
été identifiés pour le moment rappelons
que la dégradation de biens publics est
puni de 45000 euros d'amendé de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement politique également en
ce lundi avec l annonce officielle cette
fois ci de la candidature de la maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux un nouveau mandat
pas de trêve des confiseurs pour
alexandra rosetti qui vient de
s'adresser à ses habitants elle prévoit
une liste renouvelée de moitié avec en
priorité le développement durable la
maîtrise des finances ou encore l les
petits commerçants si elle reste
adhérente de l'udps et la république en
marche lui a néanmoins apporté son
soutien alexandra rosetti qui sera
l'invité du 7-8 politique le mardi 11
février à 18h45 sur tv 78 et puis
politique toujours avec un collectif qui
vient de voir le jour à magny les
hameaux
manille le bon sens il ambitionne de
monter une liste participative pour le
scrutin de mars un tract a été distribué
sur la commune le nom de son auteur est
pour l'instant un mystère le site
internet du collectif annonce des
premiers points de programme pour le
mois de janvier
autre sujet avec la spa qui tire le
bilan de son année 2010 9 à plaisir
après de fortes inquiétudes avec une
hausse des abandons durant l'été ou
encore l'animation sur paris du
rendez-vous annuel du noël des animaux
en raison des perturbations liées aux
grèves les adoptions se sont plutôt bien
passées elles sont même en hausse
écoutez la responsable du refuge de
plaisir au micro de mathilde et demi ça
année les adoptions se sont maintenus en
juin et juillet ce qui nous a permis de
continuer à cueillir plus animaux donc
d'en sauver plus et il s'avère que donc
c'était plutôt déjà de bonnes augures
cet été et il s'avère que à la rentrée
on a eu là on a une certaine visibilité
via un reportage et qui a fait beaucoup
de bien à l'ensemble de la spa ça
permettait de montrer notre travail
les gens découvraient un petit peu voilà
à l'ailé le travail des agents
animaliers la vie d'un refuge les
histoires des animaux adoptés des amis
qui est abandonnée puis qui trouve qui
sépare trouve une famille et ça a mis
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et une grande
visibilité sur la sp un portrait à
présent vous ne l'avez jamais vu
déambuler dans les allées du château de
versailles et pour cause il n'intervient
que le lundi jour de fermeture son
métier horloger et le remet les pendules
à l'heure et helvey au bon
fonctionnement de près de 80 modèles
différents
dès 8 heures bernard d'euros investi le
château de versailles le lundi jour de
fermeture au public
il connaît bien les lieux puisqu'il y
travaille comme horloger depuis 18 ans
en une demi journée j'ai fait à peu près
le tour du château et puis après il ya
les tri yann en aussi mais bon ça dépend
aussi des horloges parce que quand j'en
ai liquidés régler ou qui marchent plus
faut quand même se pencher sur son cas
bernard brault s'occupe des 75 horloge
du château de versailles
une démission de l'horloger les
remontées il débute avec cette horloge
créée par jean baptiste bâillon on
trouve des éléphants figure phare de
l'époque
là j'ai relancé l'horloge et là je la
remets à leurs homards étant à chaque
sonnerie dans l'appartement du roy
bernard drouot montrent les poids de
cette pendule à plusieurs fonctions
toutes les trois semaines
cette partie là permet de faire
fonctionner d'activer tout un système de
transmission qui déclenche qui font
marcher tout le calendrier dans l'anti
chambre de l'appartement de la reine une
autre horloge du xviiie siècle a une
particularité les cadres en duo donne
l'heure le cadran rond en dessous
indique la date
le joaillier veille sur le mécanisme
délicat d horloge il les regarde les
inspecte et s'attarde sur cette horloge
automates offerte en 1706 à louis xiv
qui fait partie du salon mercure cette
horloge ne marche pas continuellement
si tout le monde sait qu l'horloge
fonctionne ça c'est cool
tout le monde va rester ici en attendant
que lors d'un seul et donc c'est
l'émeute et la hauteur des poids est
très faible
donc si on voulait clore le jeu
fonctionne continuellement fort et cela
remonte au moins une fois par jour
horloger un métier transmis de
génération en génération bernard drouot
travail dans la société familiale depuis
ses 20 ans il est toujours aussi
minutieux toutes ces horloges ont quand
même
minimum deux sens entre 200 et 300 ans
ce sont les petits détails mais déjà
beaucoup au bruit le bruit c'est très
important
le battement du balancier le bruit qui
en résulte c'est on sent si l'horloge
est en bonne santé quoi sa santé bernard
drôle entretient avec ses nombreux
déplacements dans le château de
versailles la porte grince un peu normal
du château bernard on connaît bien les
lieux depuis 18 ans et ses anecdotes et
7 les 40 ans de beaumarchais c'est une
famille d'horlogers dont le célèbre
beaumarchais qui étaient engagés
également comme sa famille à arrêter
l'horlogerie pour se consacrer à
l'écriture aux lettres les dessous du
toit abrite l'ancienne forge de louis
saez à côté de la tringlerie elle
s'occupe de l'horloge de la cour de
marbre placée en extérieur
elle a été réalisée en 1769 c'est la
seule horloge ou leur montage est
automatique
on voit comment se taire sur les
tambours les trois mots qui alla lavéra
cagdas insa et du poids vous pouvez
remonter l'horloge toutes les semaines
pour que ça puisse fonctionner en 2000
le dispositif a été électrifiée avec des
chaînes de vélo et des moteurs
électriques
les poissons remontée et l'horloge est
autonome il faut toutefois la mettre à
l'heure comme les autres horloges dont
s'occupe bernard d'euros il travaille
aussi au sénat et au palais de justice
de paris
nous refermons ce journal avec quelques
images de nos confrères de canal plus
lors de la victoire du verrier roi ahmed
el moussaoui lors de son combat de super
welters une victoire pour le lion du rif
acquise au point lors d'une rencontre
disputée leruste abrasion s'incline il
permet aux français de confirmer l sa
bonne dynamique après son succès à bercy
le mois dernier prochaine édition du
journal demain mardi 31 décembre en
attendant les programmes se poursuivent
sur terre et 78
[Musique]